[Music]
it might sound like there's not enough
oversight of mps but in his column this
week douglas murray says unelected
officials have the real power to explain
douglas joins me now alongside james
forsythe
douglas thanks again for joining us on
spectator tv you write in your column
that the most boring conversation in the
nation is back what is it exactly
yes lord's reform
who doesn't quiver slightly when they
just hear those words
lord's reform is one of the most boring
conversations in britain because it's
essentially unsolvable and it's happened
and gone on throughout all of our
lifetimes
many of us remember the debates in the
1990s over this particularly with
getting the hereditaries down
um ever since then there's been
intermittent claims and calls for more
reform
and uh the reason it's so tedious is
because
there really aren't any good options uh
uh
intermittently people claim well just
scrap the entire chamber that's a
terrible option because you do need a
second chamber to revise legislation
every way you look at how it should be
made up you enter all sorts of trouble
and then you get the one which we're in
at the moment which is the perennial
cash for peerages debate and you know
this is serious because we all worry
about the way in which money influences
politics it's uh i think that in many
ways britain is lucky that we have less
buying of influence and then many other
democracies actually um but the the the
peerage's issue is always going to be a
strong one because
effectively if you don't have
state-funded political parties and
political parties need to raise money
through private um donors and trade
unions in the case of labor
people are going to have to be given
some incentive uh to give
millions of pounds to a political party
simply through the good of your heart or
through
something else is a strange thing to do
not very many people would do it so
there need to be inducements there are
going to be inducements and one of them
and it's an open secret is that if you
give enough money to a political party
you may find yourself able to be
suggested as being a potential peer it's
not a great system at all i i don't like
it anymore more than anyone else uh
but as i say
what are the other options
james it hasn't been a good week for the
government has it can you give us the
latest update with owen patterson
jeffrey cox and the cash for peerages
story yeah the government has basically
created a scandal that has run all week
and i think is beginning to do real
damage to the tory party
it's actions in trying to stay the um
the guilty verdict against her and
paterson
and then gonna try and reform the rules
on the back of that was so brazen it has
created a backlash
it has got everyone looking at
mp's second jobs and it has put boris
johnson in a very difficult position
he's having to choose whether to be on
the right side of public opinion uh or
the right side of his own mps because i
think if you're judging from what mps
say they're getting in their inboxes
there's no doubt that most of the public
question why mps need to have
the ability to earn money other than
their 82 000 pounds a year uh
parliamentary salary
yet uh at the same time
mps tory mps and particularly more more
traditional tory mps think uh a
they have these outside interests which
they are reluctant to give up and they
also think this is not an invalid point
that if you basically bar mps from doing
any other work other than their
parliamentary work you are going to
limit parliament to those who wish to be
professional politicians
and you are going to end you know the
ranks of kind of qcmps that you had you
know i think people think people like
ken clark or michael howard
and
i think that would narrow the experience
available to parliament and i think it
would denude parliament of quality i
think one of the problems we've already
got at the moment
is that there is a tendency for uh and
theresa may is an honorable exception to
this there's a tendency for former prime
ministers to kind of quit the comments
as soon as they've left office i think
if you if you if you banned all outside
interests i think you would find that
nearly all former cabinet ministers quit
the commons as soon as they left office
douglas you wonder in your column this
week whether trying to reform the lords
and the commas misses a crucial point do
our representatives even have that much
power in parliament anymore
yes this is something which i've been
reflecting on for a long time as i
mentioned not just in relation to the
house of lords but the house of commons
as well um you know remember one of the
the main uh the main slogan of the
brexiteers was take back control
and i say in my column this week uh
when the british public voted to take
back control from unelected bureaucrats
in brussels
i do not think that we intended to take
back that control and give it to
unelected bureaucrats in westminster
and this is a subject which as james
well knows has been bubbling for a long
time among both mps and peers about who
actually has primacy in their own houses
um now it seems to me without going into
the details of it it seems to me the
owen patterson affair has an awful lot
um
that it suggests about our democracy not
functioning well uh i believe that the
oversight that occurred was seriously
lacking
uh and it and you know
basically what occurred would have been
impossible in a judicial set up owen
patterson effectively wanted his day in
court was not given it partly because
the person who was judging him is not a
judge
um she's an absolutely typical
archetypal bureaucrat
um
and there was so much wrong in her
investigation but then you end up in
this position of course which was made
much worse by the the ridiculous
u-turning of the boris johnson
government i mean if you're going to
spend political capital as they were
going to do
spend it and and and see it through
don't spend it and then then you turn at
the first uh cries of complaint but but
the real thing is not just the oversight
of mps and the oversight of mp's um
extracurricular or extra activities
but also in the same in the house of
lords
james douglas is pointing out here that
he thinks that the oversight mechanisms
currently in place can sometimes be too
powerful that's certainly something the
allies of owen patterson have been
saying these past few weeks on the flip
side of course especially in light of
the jeffrey cox revelations you have
people saying that there simply hasn't
been enough oversight but it feels to me
like we're getting to a far broader
point here and perhaps a more crucial
one which is
what is the job of an mp and how much
time and dedication should be put into
that craft as opposed to other kinds of
work
so i i personally think that having mps
who
uh carry on with their former
professions and trades while they are
back bench mps
can be healthy um for example just
constitutionally we have an attorney
general and a solicitor general in our
system and an advocate general for
scotland they all need to be lawyers so
you do need a certain number of lawyers
to be practicing in the house of commons
and you know i think you know michael
howard and ken clark are examples of the
fact that you can combine a successful
legal career at the bar with a
successful parliamentary and political
career
and
that i think is healthy i think where
things become more dubious
is when mps are being paid for kind of
political intelligence or things like
that
rather than thought for carrying on with
the jobs that they were doing but i also
think we have to make choices as a
country uh i think we lament the fact
that there are so many professional
politicians in the house of commons we
lament the fact that there are so many
if one was being unkind kind of super
counsellors in the house of commons
if you don't want to have that then you
are going to need to allow us to have a
system that does allow people to uh not
to have to entirely give up their
previous careers when they become
politicians and i think that is that is
striking that balance now i think you
can get into specific arguments about
how long people should be away or not uh
and i think jeffrey cox the fact that
jeffrey cox has spoken so little in the
house of commons uh in recent times
doesn't do him any favors
but theoretically i have no issue with
someone being a qc and carrying on
earning more from their legal practice
than they do as a backbench mp as long
as they are speaking and participating
in debates
and generally raising the tone of uh
just scrutiny of legislation in the
house of commons and i think this
applies this argument applies um
even more forcefully to the house of
lords if you are to hugely restrict what
lords can do then i think there are
fewer people will enter the house of
lords because the the dirty secret about
the house of lords is but the house of
lords doesn't have very much power and
the households will never be reformed
because the house of commons does not
want the house of lords to be reformed
in a way because if a house of lawrence
was reformed it would have to be given
more power it would have to be more of a
check on the house of commons than it
currently is and the house of commons
doesn't want that
can i just add one point i agree with
what james says there's one point that's
very important here which is that um the
example he cites of um lawyers uh having
as it were
continuing their careers
is is a pertinent one and also it needs
to be caveated it cannot be the case
that the commons is filled with um uh
full-time mps
and um part-time mps who are also
part-time lawyers and i say that because
it cannot be the case that only
practicing lawyers continue to practice
of course in the commons
because we can't have
in my view
an ever increasing legalization of the
political class
one of the things that the commons needs
is voices for representing all sorts of
different opinions including opinions
have nothing to do with the
legality of questions but respond to the
constituents concerns about issues um
all sorts of of areas of our country
have nothing to do with the law have
things to do with everyday concerns of
people so so as i say there shouldn't be
a sort of super mp who is also
a practicing lawyer but it is it is
tricky terrain um as we know i think
that there are good law um good rules in
place uh regarding uh
as james says sort of really dodgy areas
like political consultancy um
but but but this has to be said because
um
oh and i added one other thing by the
way which is james is totally right
about this complete confusion among us
in the general public
on these issues of mps and mp's pay we
say we don't want professional
politicians uh but we don't like people
from other professions either um
we we say that uh we want people to go
into politics with a wealth of
experience and then we expect them to
completely cut off that experience when
they get into politics this gets back to
something i think has been a problem in
our country for a while which is a sort
of
a desire effectively
with some good cause to sort of punish
the political class to catch the
politicians and the mps in particular
kind of vice between between two things
that are screwing towards them and
keeping them locked in place i don't
think it's healthy it's not a
particularly healthy instinct for us to
have either as a public
james last word to you
so i i obviously it shouldn't just be
lawyers that you have now sometimes you
should have people from from from all
walks of life but i think that lawyers
illustrate the problem with trying to
have a kind of blanket ban on all
outside interests which i think is
something that is going to gain traction
as an idea uh uh following the way that
the
the government has behaved in recent
weeks and the longer this scandal goes
on the more
uh inclination there will be for the
government to reach for some big
dramatic thing to try and move the story
on and i think that would be a mistake i
mean and so i think that is the problem
we've got to deal with i think we also
need to
work out that i think that the one of
the crucial points that douglas makes is
parliament has now had powers returned
to it and i think what we've got to see
is that parliament is prepared to use
the powers that has had returned to it
and that parliament is prepared to
properly hold the executive
to account and parliament is prepared to
take more responsibility for its own
effect
by the way i know you said the last word
to james but can we just have a moment
also to observe like a minute silence
the complete horlicks that this
government is capable of making of
absolutely everything from the smallest
uh uh scandal to the biggest there is
nothing that number 10 at the moment it
doesn't seem to be capable of blowing up
into a huge storm it's quite remarkable
to watch
[Music]
you